good morning millennials welcome back
oh my god welcome back to the morning
toast stand happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend happy friday jackie
happy friday toasters welcome you guys i
mean at times it felt like it might
never come but an uphill battle that's
the beauty of the week if you stick it
out it will eventually be friday that's
true if you build it friday will come if
you persevere
it will be here and i'm so excited that
we are all together on this friday it's
it's a very friday friday i know there's
like magic in the air magic in the air
tis the season and i'm just really
excited to embark on my weekend i am too
oh my god your water bottle just like
pops my water bottle's excited to embark
on the weekend well you know what i'm
definitely feeling the friday vibes but
i have a lot to accomplish here at the
morning toast before i can set foot
peacefully into friday because
i worked so hard for the toasters
yesterday i watched literally everything
on tv okay i watched the episodes that
are available of and just like that
which we will be recapping and we will
be giving spoilers it is the fifth story
the fifth story into the tv recap there
will be a major spoiler because a major
thing happened yeah and but we'll let
you know before you're good right now
we'll let you know we'll give you time i
watched the entire season of um the sex
lives of college girls and i absolutely
must put it in the tv recap i also
finished ultimate girls trip real
housewives which i know you did too yeah
so we will be discussing recapping and
chatting about that in the tv recap how
many episodes are there of sex in the
city two oh okay but they're about an
hour they're not the classic 30 minute
episodes got it i'm really looking
forward to hearing your thoughts it's a
lot like
words
it's a lot it looks like a lot it feels
like a lot i would be surprised if it
was anything less than a lot so
yeah i mean obviously there's this major
spoiler everyone's talking about but
also there was a lot going on like with
the characters that i found to be just
as interesting specifically my girl
miranda okay i'm excited to hear about
it in the tv recap and to talk about
real housewives ultimate girls trip i
have so many thoughts and i don't know
if i've ever had less popular opinions
in my life oh i know what it's gonna be
we'll talk about it yeah but i was
looking on twitter and like i didn't
even see one rogue person that agreed
with you who agrees with me or anything
like that
it was also a lot and i have yeah we
just there's a lot to break down today
and there's a lot of news a lot of legal
news a lot of us justice judicial system
doing their thing yeah some verdicts
were coming down yesterday and justice
has been served some verdicts were
coming down some gavels were coming down
pretty hard as well
yes i'm gonna hang on to this because
i'm feeling today's episode might be a
little judicial it's going to be quite
judicial and i uh it could jump in feels
a little premature i'm ready because
like i was saying i'm so here to like
dive into friday but not before i do my
job to the fullest extent of the law and
i have a lot to say today okay so maybe
we just dive right in any personal
updates no no i literally like was a
disgusting piece of [ __ ] yesterday who
watched so much television for my job so
it's it's acceptable um
and that's like what i did all all
[ __ ] day well thank you for your
service and just a little book update
i've been reading a lot and watching a
lot of tv finished inheriting
inheritance games um
i just like i'm so annoyed that i wasted
my time and now like you know no i feel
like then i started the new jody pickle
book wish you were here and
you know she's like such an acclaimed
author and never heard of her yes you i
think she wrote my sister's keeper i've
actually never read a jody pickle book
but you would recognize all the titles
yeah for sure because they're made into
movies and so her new book like just
dropped and i was cautiously
choosing it because it is about the
pandemic
oh and so it starts like red flags it
starts march 13th 2020 red [ __ ] flag
but i
it's a
so far it's not triggering okay and i'm
about 15 in and because she like she's
supposed to go on a trip like on march
14th and she still goes and she gets
like stuck on the island
because that's cute so it's not like
it's not about cove but it's just her
circumstances and if in the book are due
to the covenant circumstances okay
that's not bad so i'm i'm reading
cautiously i will keep you guys posted
because like
no yeah but so far so good so that's my
reading update and um i will continue to
share with you i feel like if i keep
going at this rate i might hit a hundred
no like so my goal is always 50. this is
my 60th book oh i thought you were gonna
get close to 100. last year i read 65
books i did not think i was going to top
last year you will because we're going
on like a low-key mountain vacation like
if i don't choose any books that are
like more than 500 pages i could
probably do it yeah
um whenever you hold these gavels do you
feel the need to touch your knee like
you did at the doctor like to check your
reflexes
you just faked that yeah for sure what
am i supposed to feel you're supposed to
it's supposed to be a reflex that's the
point
am i a serial killer let me bang it
oh my god no do yours okay
i think also your leg is supposed to be
hanging off the doctor's table like i
don't think this counts and also i think
it's like when you know it's coming
because you're administering it oh
that's a really good call it's a little
you are so smart sometimes thank you and
probably not even right but it sounded
good so i was hoping to reach my
goodreads goal of 30 books um and i'm
ready at like 26 and i just haven't been
able to pick up my kindle but i'm hoping
just to like bang out five while we're
on vacation yeah you'll you'll do great
the hard part is finding the books yes
send me recommendations for like really
cute
twisty turny short books
i'm trying to hit a goal here okay
no it's so funny in like the redheads
facebook group everyone's like i'm
trying to hit my reading goal because
someone people recommend some short book
get some crap like no but it could be
good read frannie and zoe
that was like 90 pages but it was tough
i might just do that you know you would
you i think you would actually hate it i
think you'd be better off reading like
300 pages about the odyssey of colleen
hoover i [ __ ] love colleen hoover
that's easy i would read like a 500 page
calling whoever did you read layla
no because that was the one colleen
hoover book you told me i wouldn't like
well
i have a kimberly that haven't spoken
about this at the red hat so modest i'm
so mad it's no at the redheads we are
currently running reader's choice best
book of 2021 because the editor's choice
with all the hosts was so controversial
what book one from the editor so it was
bait everyone gave their top three picks
and then if you your third pick got a
score of one your second pick got a
score of two and your first pick gets a
score of three and then i added up all
of the numbers
and because dana and i had the same
number one book the book that book won
that book is also margo and rebecca's
least favorite book that we read this
year so it was clara and the sun
but it's also like written by like a
nobel laureate like it is a good book
but it was just not the redheads cup of
tea so yeah i posted like that's the
redheads book of the year and the people
were quaking so i said you know what
let's take it let's do a reader's choice
and it's pretty shocking you are such
like a community manager of the redheads
like you know and i feel like you don't
even talk a lot about the redheads it's
so successful it's like one of our most
successful adventures it's really like
these are almost at 50k on instagram
that's crazy it really brings me so much
joy and nachos and i love
every part of it
and
it's looking like the midnight library
is going to be the reader's choice best
of yours no that was dana's and honestly
it was my number two i'm totally okay
with that but shockingly layla comes in
at number two
it's colleen hoover yeah
and long no and i think you would like
it and the redheads liked it and you
like i drive with the red hair usually
in line with them you know i drive for
sure so i i need to join a book club
podcast full of like you know
snitch's choices no no because you know
what snitch's choices are not even my
genre i thought that they were and then
she made me read american royals and i
never trusted her again and she's like
stands by that decision i need a book
club full of like bored housewives who
are looking for like cute erotics
romantic comedies i think there are so
many book clubs like that i actually
think that's like the stereotypical book
club and i think that's the one i need
to join yeah maybe you guys are too
scholarly for me i think well it's every
every month is it's a mixed bag it's a
mixed bag yeah because dana's really
scholarly i think rebecca and i are
pretty much like on the same wavelengths
of like niches sometimes we're like
genre fluid but we do love historical
fiction and then snitch comes in with to
bring the the age average slightly down
yeah and to bring the pornography
slightly up that's what i love you know
what you might like
even though like we all look back on it
and we're like no but
but it was just like a
it was a i think you might like it red
white and royal blue oh you know what
i've gotten recommended that a bunch of
times yeah i would have read it even if
it wasn't a redhead's choice because it
was coming up on so many lists
and i think you might like it okay
so yeah five more books i think i can do
it i think you can do it too she's gonna
do it you guys no i'm definitely gonna
do it yeah even if i have to just like
catalog some dr seuss books you know
yeah yeah no you you'll be great you're
also such a fast reader i think you're a
faster reader than me i'm extremely fast
yeah
because
um
my font is so big on my kindle that's my
little hack
that's insane you read so fast when your
font is enormous but like you get carpal
tunnel now from tap tap tapping no tap
tap tap it on the glass
waving through a window
all right let's jump in
i i do feel ready now and also if you
are redhead make sure to go vote in the
final poll it's up on our instagram
story i want everyone's voices to be
heard on this one without further ado it
is time for the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
the pill club if you're on birth control
remembering to take your pill is already
enough work forget going to the doctor
in person to get your prescription and
picking it up from the pharmacy the pill
club wants to help you take the work out
of taking care of yourself the pill club
carries over 120 fda approved brands
most brands of birth control are free
with insurance or medicaid otherwise
prices start as low as 9 a month without
insurance the pill club delivers birth
control to your door for free and
discreet packaging and their licensed
medical team is just a text away to give
you the best reproductive health care
skip the office skip the waiting line
and join the club right now when you go
to thepillclub.com
toast the pill club is offering a 10
donation to bedcider.org for every
morning toast listener who becomes a
patient your donation will help
low-income individuals get access to
birth control through bedcider.org
that's thepillclub.com
toast to get your first birth control
care package and donate to help more
women in need of affordable birth
control remember the pill club.com
toast you must use that link to make
sure the donation goes through
great okay our first story big news
justice millett is guilty of staging a
race-baiting hate attack to boost his
career guilty on five out of six counts
nearly three years after he claimed two
trump-loving bigots beat him up tied a
noose around his neck and doused him in
bleach jesse smellette was convicted
thursday of staging a hate crime in a
misbegotten bid to raise his public
profile 12 i didn't realize that was the
reason behind that
yeah i mean like
like it crossed my mind but it wasn't i
wasn't sure that was a verified don't
this is the article this article seems a
little editorial
liberties it's the new york post 12
jurors in chicago criminal court found
the disgraced actor guilty of five of
six counts of fellow felony disorderly
conduct for filing a false police report
following testimony from 13 witnesses
and more than nine hours of deliberation
as the jurors read out the verdict he
stood huddled with his attorneys and
kept his eyes trained on the pal
panelists and remained stoic
the actor who took more than an hour to
return to the courthouse to hear the
jury's verdict now faces up to three
years in jail was later seen embracing
his siblings and family following the
verdict his lead defense attorney said
that the actor plans to fight the
conviction on appeal he said quote he's
committed to clearing his name and he's
100 confident that he's going to get
cleared by the appellate court
unfortunately sure jen sure
unfortunately that's not the route we
wanted but sometimes that's the route
you have to take to win especially a
case where we remain 100 confident in
our clients innocence that is so
delusional you know what i'm actually
hear my questions
i know that this is like a gross misjust
misuse of police resources but is this
something you go to jail for
um like relying on the police yeah yeah
well he faces up to three years in jail
but it's possible he could also get out
with like a year of community service
after all so but yes it seems as though
he might go to jail for this he lied to
the police i saw today that he used a
hundred thousand dollars of police
resources oh is he getting fined for
that on this little stunt
i didn't see anything about fines um
okay well that was my first question and
my second question is like
does juicy have like a lot of money
because like to keep fighting it's a lot
of legal expenses like
i'm curious how he's paying for this
because
he was on empire for like a good amount
of time and he definitely got paid a lot
but he hasn't been working in three
years yeah so i'm just curious wow i
can't believe that was three years ago
you know i know i saw a clip the other
day of his robin roberts interview like
it was just like going was this before
it was
exposed that it was fake before it was
exposed that it was fake where he's
talking and he says
i will never and he's like very you know
somber and
like chronicling what happened to him
and he said i will never be a person
that this didn't happen to
and it's actually that's exactly who you
are no it's it's really
empowering to watch it now like now
knowing you know what's also hiring to
watch i came up on my tick tock this
morning
like clips of what you know different
media
news channels were talking about before
this was exposed as being fraudulent so
like just seeing um
it was that woman who was on roseanne i
think she's like roseanne's sister she's
on the talk like promoting roseanne but
obviously no one can talk about anything
else and she's just going so hard and
she's like and there are people who are
doubting juicy and and it's just
terrible and i'm like she had good
intentions obviously i don't think she's
a bad person but it's so awkward to
watch it now knowing all that we know
all these different news clips it's just
hindsight is just
20 20 and
it's painful to watch it will never not
be like the crazy the craziest thing
when i think about it and i just
remember i can't believe it was three
years ago all right but i just remember
when like it never would have crossed my
mind no that someone could be fibbing
especially because we're just living in
such terrible times so it was such a
believable lie
and i think well no it's just because
who would lie like right
you don't fathom that some that that
this could be made up yeah but sadly
like hate crimes happen a lot yes so
it's right it's not unfathomable exactly
so when it happened it was just
and like everyone was so impacted by it
i don't think there wasn't a celebrity
who didn't speak out on it like it was
just this horrific horrific story
that never happened it's just
it'll never blow my mind it'll never not
be the craziest thing i ever lived
through honestly yeah not to be dramatic
no no it is that crazy and if you're
gonna do something as crazy as staging
your own hate crime
the levels of messiness
that this plan included like the checks
and literally rolling up to the hardware
store to get rope like it was just so
poorly planned for something so
egregious and something so unethical
because like there are so many people
who actually are victims of hate crimes
and like this just like is like a
statement but to like
play on existing divisions to just boost
your career yeah it's
so twisted it ain't right and also i
don't know how i mean if you are going
to see
maybe there are ways to he could have
you know ordered the rope on amazon kept
it on no but still it would be on his
amazon like in this day and age you know
if he's sending them the script of what
to say like that there's a paper trail
unless you know maybe he should have
worded a pen and paper and then right
burned it
yeah
it's just
i'm grateful the saga's behind us
because it was like the worst of
humanity
so and the justice system did her thing
and juicy will
i guess pay the price
like the fact that he's still
maintaining that this happens okay but
let's be real
what else could he do like admitting do
you know how embarrassing this is this
is like like his fa his sister journey
is also like famous like he has other
people to think about like this is
mortifying
i don't know if i was him in this
situation i don't think i would ever be
in this situation i'm not sure what rude
i would take okay because admitting the
truth is so humiliating yeah but lying
under oath
but perhaps okay say you want to stick
to your story you've made you've come
this far yeah right to go to appeals
court or even suggest that you might no
i know like once i would be found guilty
i think i would like let the jig up like
i would put my case to rest yeah but
maybe in some delusional way like he
really thinks he's innocent because it
takes a really unwell person
mentally to do something like this so
maybe in his own way he does think i'm
just trying to rationalize because this
is the most moronic story and it just
keeps getting weirder so i'm just trying
to rationalize like maybe he does think
he's innocent in his own special way
in his own special way just a thought
well speaking of unwell people in the
justice system josh duggar has been
found guilty on child pornography
charges facing potential 40-year prison
sentence lazy liberty doing her thing
yesterday josh duggar's fate has been
sealed a jury on thursday found the
former reality star political activist
and father of seven political activists
for who i don't know guilty
of two charges of unknowingly receiving
and possessing child pornography also
known as child sexual abuse material he
faces up to 20 years of imprisonment and
up to 250 000 in fines for each
conviction though because possession is
a lesser included offense he will
technically only be sentenced for the
receipt crime
say that again
i don't understand his sentencing is
expected in four months but a date
hasn't been scheduled having a
pre-sentence investigation so we'll find
out eventually how long it's going to be
this is glorious news um i did see a
report
that some of the evidence that was
brought into trial proved that he was
like consuming and sharing child
pornography of a child that's three
months old okay so this is the type of
[ __ ] lunatic monster disgusting
pervert we're working with and i pray to
god this man spends the rest of his life
in prison i think he's disgusting i
think his family is disgusting and i
think the fact that we've known he's a
pedophile for so long and he's just now
like
being brought up on serious charges it's
just insane because his family was
protecting him i hate this man with
every fiber of my being and i hope he
has a miserable [ __ ] life i had seen
some anecdotes over like the course of
the trial of what was found and it's so
troublesome
disgusting troublesome
twisted
it's
it's makes you sick to your stomach i
know it's so awful and
seriously like
i hope in some way this investigation is
helpful in you know it's like uh
leading them to
i don't think he wasn't manufacturing
those images so i hope this is like you
know one cog in the machine but for now
i'm grateful justice was served for this
absolute animal
and
i hope obviously there's more benefits
that come after yeah but when you do
think about
like where this leads and like you know
how many other people
have he's one of a million who makes
these images how many other people make
image it is so
twisted twisted
the world that we live in it's so
disgusting
and seriously
death to them all
death death
but
bright side
justice has been served yes you know
we're two for three on public trials you
know we just have delane left it's been
a very legal judicial like a couple
weeks it has been and i i just want to
brace everyone like i don't think we're
going to get what we need either in the
lane situation and it's really
disappointing and i'm doing like
everything i can not to turn into a
full-blown conspiracy theorist but i
have literally not seen this trial being
covered on any major news channels
outlets i'm seeing it on like random
twitter accounts and i'm trying not to
fall into like a deep dark hole of
conspiracy but there's just so much out
there to consume conspiracy wise and i
have a feeling it's not conspiracy if
it's the truth thank you um i just have
a feeling like we're going to get
absolutely nothing absolutely the room
was closed like everything execution is
like bundling they're about to rest i
think yeah they like so much stuff that
would have been illuminating has been
like kept private it's
we're getting nothing you guys so i have
a list i'm checking it twice juicy check
excuse me
uh josh jugger check galain
i don't think we're gonna go three for
three i really don't know and it's i
mean maybe she'll be found get like
maybe she will spend time in prison and
whatever but you know it's not gonna be
this it's not going to be this big
exposure where all the roaches come out
no we're not getting that nothing of the
sort no and that's what we thought we
were getting and oh how we have been i
think we always knew
i don't know there was a time where you
couldn't fart without hearing jeffrey
epstein's name like it was just such a
conversation with such a part of the
culture jeffrey epstein didn't kill
himself all that stuff that you thought
in no way can like these people escape
public scrutiny and we've forgotten we
have all forgotten no i don't think it's
the people that have no you're right
yeah
so
that's disappointing but we'll cross
that bridge when we're coming out there
are you ready for our next story if it's
a story that's brought to you by pros
have you noticed some hair starting to
shed after you have your baby that can
be really common i know that's something
you're really thinking about
and it can be really concerning so after
pregnancy your body is shifting
recalibrating and doing things that
don't feel normal one of the alarming
side effects of the hormonal changes can
be excessive shedding which is hair that
comes out in clumps even when you wash
it or brush it thankfully we have pros
to stop the shedding cycle and grow back
your hair pros specializes in custom
hair care and now they also make custom
hair supplements that are personally
tailored to address your specific cause
of shedding so you could shed for a
multitude of reasons like i know a lot
of people who have experienced hair loss
whether they're just going through
stressful times obviously postpartum and
it's nice to have something
in your home that can prepare you for
this they take into account things like
hormonal changes stress level diet and
more and the result is customized
supplements guaranteed to help you grow
thicker longer softer hair in record
time they're made with clean safe and
natural ingredients the pros hair
supplements are just two capsules you
take daily the first strengthens and
rebalances the scalp to reduce shedding
and the second capsule helps to spark
fuller faster deep deeper growth in the
follicle
multiple studies show that over 90
percent of women taking pros hair
supplements saw less shedding more
growth and improved overall appearance
in just 90 days try your own custom hair
supplements and you'll get 15 off when
you go to pros.com toast that's
p-r-o-s-e
dot com slash toast for your free
in-depth hair consultation and 15 off
custom hair supplements wonderful
our next story kanye west
west asks kim kardashian to quote run
right back to me baby during the benefit
concert kanye is making another public
plea for reconciliation to his estranged
wife kim while performing at the free
lab larry hoover concert thursday at the
la coliseum kanye dedicated his song
runaway to kim after singing the lyrics
i need you to run right back to me baby
the rapper added more specifically
kimberly oh wow
kim attended the concert with her sister
kendall and her mom chris she also
brought along two of her kids north and
saint i definitely feel like kim and
kanye are going to get back together
together eventually but i think kim is
going to make kanye like work extremely
hard for it and they embarrass himself
multiple times publicly okay i agree but
i also i just don't want kim to like
overplay the hand because then like
it just takes one split second for the
him to get fed up for the person who's
chasing to be like i'm done yeah and
then it's too late so i hope that you i
think kim has like a good gauge on i
think she'll know i hope the timing's
right but also like seeing all this and
obviously like it's every week now where
he makes some sort of public plea with
him which like you know the stands just
love to see yeah um
it's making me question like what
happened between them because it's like
he
it seemed kind of like amicable like you
want to live this way i want to live
this way you know it's not really
working between us but now it's almost
like he's asking for forgiveness yeah
well i think the way that they were
living was because of kanye like he
never came home he was always in
idaho right wyoming wyoming um
and i think like kim's like okay so
that's life you want good because it's
the life you get and it's like actually
no like i miss my family you know connie
is very like family oriented and i think
like knowing that his family was waiting
for him is one thing but knowing that
like they're living separate lives is
probably another yeah and now when you
think about it like he sold the wyoming
ranch or at very least it's on the
market he bought a house in malibu like
he's committed
to living in cali so i think she's
making him do like a list of things
she's waiting a good amount of time like
making him jealous
and in the meantime she's you know she's
having a great time
um this works for me me too
uh i just hope that the timing that they
don't miss each other do you know what i
mean yeah like she's playing hard to get
he's chasing and then like just when
she's about to give in he gives up yeah
he meets someone and it's like yeah no
i've been pursuing him and she won't
even give me like she's never coming
home right because it's like humiliating
like over and over to keep putting
yourself out there i don't brutally
rebuff yes but like i don't find this to
be like embarrassing on kanye's part i
find it to be really sweet me too and i
also don't think like humiliation is a
feeling kanye is really capable of
feeling because he's just so confident
in himself right like that's not a
feeling he can really feel i think right
and for kim it's like the best feeling
she's dating like america's bachelor
while you know
kanye is just waiting in the wings no
that's nice and you know what she waited
at home for him for so long so no it's
his turn to wait
did you see anything else from the
concert
no i didn't really um
i didn't know that it was on or else i
would have watched it like i was in such
watching mode you know what i watched i
mean i at least i tried really late zach
was up so late watching oh really
it was like streamed right yeah it was
on amazon prime well i um again watched
so much stuff yesterday just because i'm
amazing at my job and i did start to
watch the travis scott charlemagne
interview
and i wanted to do it for my people so i
could come on here and recap it but i i
really i could not make it past like six
minutes it's 50 minutes
it is it's clear from the get-go he's
taking absolutely no responsibility so
i've got message received i don't need
to watch the whole hour and to be honest
and i know this is like so ironic coming
for me because every other word out of
my mouth is like like like like like
totally like like
travis is just you know uh you know yeah
like you know and i'm like
i sound like that too but i like it was
just it was filled with nothing it's tom
sandoval yeah you know you know
and you know what
i'm now conscious of how many times i
say you know because it doesn't sound
good
other people are like as other people's
you know yeah you know it's not great
i do think it's better than like because
there's less of a stigma around it yeah
we'll get there don't worry yeah but i
agree but the whole message of the
interview is that he's taking no
accountability so i don't really know
why i needed an hour of that he said it
in the first couple minutes okay
yeah and i don't think well i actually
didn't watch the whole thing so i can't
really say i don't think charlemagne was
hitting him with like the hard
questions questions okay but
there
44 minutes if you want to watch watch
let me know i just and i couldn't like
gather from the comments what the
general reception was all the comments
were really just like praying for the
families yeah so i'm not sure like what
the interview accomplished
got it
well speaking of pete davidson sort of
miley cyrus and pete davidson revealed
they got matching tattoos after snl in
2017.
miley and pete used to share a secret
tattoo the singer and the comedian
stopped by the tonight show starring
jimmy fallon thursday to promote their
new year's eve special while there they
revealed they once got matching tattoos
after appearing in an snl sketch
together they both starred in the shows
the baby step sketch which aired in 2017
and also featured larry david before
launching into the story of their
matching ink pete joked it was a very
dark time in our lives with cyrus saying
that we were dressed as babies
everything seemed fun and fine so after
the sketch they
felt inspired to get something tattoos
like that said we uh we babies
but i guess pizza has burned off since
and it's so embarrassing for me still
has hers i'm like i saw a lot of promo
about this interview well because
they're doing promo they're hosting new
year's eve together right yeah or she's
it's her thing
oh no they're hosting it together sorry
and so then they went on the tonight
show last night and miley like sang
something and it was like funny ha ha um
i feel like tacky promo like this is so
beneath pete yeah this is like so miley
like this is her she loves like kitschy
um tonight show stupidity but
i feel like pete is so like not this
no this whole thing was just uh corny
corny weird i don't know and uh unclear
i'm not understanding like what's going
on and they got
tattoos no that's like hella
embarrassing like you got tattoos with
someone and like there's mysteriously
burned off like you're left with this
moronic tattoo yeah but i guess when you
have so many tattoos it doesn't matter
it's not like the biggest deal you just
get something that you think is cute or
funny yeah
i don't know yeah i know this is like
classic
celebrity clickbait yes i know but good
to know that they're hosting new year's
eve together even though like you know i
used to
literally when we were growing up like i
used to [ __ ] love that show like
wrecking dick and clark rockin dicken
dicken rocket eve dick clark's rockin
eve yes i used to love it it was like
really like a cornerstone of like my
childhood and i can't think of anything
i would rather watch less now well
that's also i think what it's meant to
do you know it's for the kids and the
families and then eventually you grow up
and you go to the clubs and it's like
who the [ __ ] is sitting at home watching
this no no but even if i'm home like we
were home on new year's
last year and we were watching were we
we were watching some program that's the
same program actually i don't know if we
watched anything i think we just like
had a club you know i'm saying like it's
not because i'm not home it's just
because like it's all pre-recorded now
like everyone's lip-syncing and it's
like i'm just too smart to watch it no
and yeah i i agree i do think it has
gotten gone down like yes we've gotten
older but it has gone down it has right
like when we were like 12 that was like
the height of it it had to have been
yeah and it felt like you know to be
asked to perform like as the ball drops
on nbc is like the height of your career
whereas like now it's like who can we
get to show up at midnight right but is
that just because we're old or like do
kids today like live for the ball
dropping i don't know i also think of
like the thanksgiving day parade where
it's like i still think that when we
were growing up it was like the miley
cyrus jonah's brother's like oh my god
that's the coolest thing yeah and now
i'm watching him as an adult and i'm
like they couldn't pay these people
enough to come okay i think that the
macy's thanksgiving day parade like
really still has its
prestige i agree but i
it has it it has and i will watch it
like till until i'm dead but it just
felt like growing up like the performers
maybe because it was targeted to us like
that's also just a kid like you don't
realize that they're lip syncing and
it's like oh sparkly lights like it's
all very impressive but i think it
actually ages very well
yes no parade now being older i'm like
you know they're it's not
the most a-list no no no but it felt
like a plus growing up yes but i do
think for the most part the thanksgiving
day parade is still like a really
prestigious
thing i think people still love it 100
and i don't think dick and rock and eve
has the same
effect we'd have to talk to the campers
yeah is that like their life is that
their go-to right i don't know i don't
think so i mean now it's ryan seacrest
yeah it was ryan seacrest when we were
kids he was the guy we never encountered
dick no i don't think we were dick's
dicks girlies
[Laughter]
yeah i don't think we are
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story that's gonna lead into the
tv recap that is also going to spoil and
just like that so take a moment if you
haven't watched in just like that and
you don't want it to be spoiled i would
skip probably the next 10 minutes of the
episode okay
yeah we'll try to flag you back in okay
yeah if i can remember when you see me
go like this
come back okay and if you're listening
as a podcast i'm just really sorry yeah
give it 10 minutes maybe we'll try and
get a time stamp in the description yeah
okay i'm looking right now for how long
it takes us for when you can come back
in yeah
the final story
peloton responds to the death of sex in
the city
truckers for
responding to the death of sex and the
city character in first episode of and
just like that so here's the spoiler
in the first episode carrie and mr big
are enjoying wedded bliss only for their
happiness to come to an abrupt halt when
big suffers a fatal heart attack after a
45-minute ride on his at-home peloton
bike so there's like so much promo for
the peloton like before we find out that
it's the thing that kills him and it
feels just like a classic sponsored
thing like he's talking about how he
loves allegra and he's about to do his
thousandth ride and he loves the peloton
pelton valentine and then it's like the
symphony they go to um
charlotte's daughter's piano recital and
she's playing this like gorgeous
symphony and as she's playing it he's on
the bike and the thing is climbing and
he's climbing and then she drops the
piano and he drops out
that is so crazy i saw this morning a
meme that was like peloton when they
found out they're getting to be on sex
and city
peloton when they watch the episode
and by the way peloton stock is dropping
okay what did they respond so this is
what they responded um because it seemed
sponsored but it's obviously not a
member of peloton's health and wellness
advisory council and preventative
cardiologist said in a statement to the
la times that while she sure quotes sex
and the city fans like me are saddened
by the news that mr big dies of a heart
attack the fact that he was on the
exercise bike just beforehand has little
to do with his death mr big lived what
many would call an extravagant lifestyle
including cocktails cigars and big
steaks and was at serious risk as he had
a previous cardiac event in season six
yes he had an angina these lifestyle
choices and perhaps even his family
history which often is a significant
factor where the likely cause of his
death riding his peloton bike may have
even helped delay his cardiac event okay
so like steve is all like why was he on
the bike and miranda says like very like
directly the bike didn't kill him so i
think they like tried to make it seem
like it wasn't the bike but it was just
like a very it almost seemed like an
intentional attack attack on peloton
like whoever
okay it's like whoever wrote this script
has a lot of stake in soul cycle bikes
yeah no i agree this is a really i mean
i'm sure this is a very real thing that
could happen and i'm sure that it does
happen but that is a really
crazy choice and if you do want to kill
him like from his at home don't use the
lane
bike yeah couldn't they just say the
stationary bike yeah or i'm just gonna
cycle at home yeah or like yeah totally
so
i didn't watch it but that's just a
really crazy thing and the fact that
they this spokesperson has to talk about
like biggs lifestyle choices and like
this fictional character and it's just
like it's so stupid but can we talk
about like the fact that they killed big
off like they brought the show back it
was supposed to be like it's a light and
fun show i just said it's my comfort
show and it got so serious so fast and
when you said yesterday that like they
killed someone off i
had heard that big was gonna die and so
when
when you confirmed it like i knew that
it was big um
and it was like hella sad like i
actually did cry like the whole second
episode is like preparing for the
funeral and the actual funeral and it's
really sad and like she gets his ashes
like it's so dark and so bizarre
um
they do that with every like sex in the
city ever since they wrapped it's like
what's the worst thing that could happen
carrie gets left at the altar what's the
worst thing that can happen she cheats
on big what's the worst that can happen
big dies and it's like we why couldn't
we watch the ten years of wedded bliss
yeah no but they have this like fabulous
apartment they were being so cute like
and they do talk about kovid they're not
they're they're acting like we're living
in a completely post code world like
they're going out to dinner waiting for
a restaurant they're not wearing masks
they're like oh remember we used to have
to wear masks like it's fine it's not
bothering me because it's not like a
main storyline um
but i'm really struggling with the show
between like absolutely like despising
it and also like kind of really loving
it and here's why
the
okay i actually have something to say
for why i hate it okay so she's on a
podcast
and she's like this like kind of like
old woman on the podcast and they're
talking about like sex and anal and
she's like getting really quiet and her
boss is like you've got to step your
[ __ ] up that's what she said like this
is a podcast sometimes we're gonna go
there and you have to be able to go
there like you were writing about sex in
the 90s in a newspaper like you can do
that so she goes home and tries to step
her [ __ ] up and she asks big to
masturbate in front of him in front of
her and like we watch it it was
it was horrifying you watch it did they
show penis no no no no but like it's
just like two people sitting on a bed
like one's masturbating the other one's
watching okay it was horrifying so it's
[ __ ] like that that like they're trying
to like i don't know make
kind of shocking moments like they used
to have it's just not cutting it and not
to be mean or ageist but like watching
an old man masturbate is just not my
idea of a good time i'm sorry
maybe if it was like when he was younger
i would have enjoyed it i'm sorry not to
be ages it was kind of disgusting i
think that that's okay that is really
it's just [ __ ] like that you know okay
i'm really feeling very comfortable in
my choice not to watch but but okay wait
but i also just want to say like as to
covid and tv and like coming to this
place where it's like
it used to be like i don't want to see
it i don't want to smell it get it away
like we it's hard enough living in it
yeah but now it's like we have to live
in this hellscape and it's not fair to
watch tv shows where like they don't
have to deal with it right you know and
it just makes it makes you like more
aware of how different things are that's
actually true so i don't know what the
right answer is because on the one hand
i'm like i want to hear about you know i
want you to represent reality on the
other hand i'm like escape yeah yeah
yeah no so it's frustrating it's like
even on when i'm watching real
housewives and or reality tv and like
they're wearing masks and situations
that do not call for maths i'm like what
are you doing it's performative it's
right so i i don't even know how i feel
about it i just know like whatever
everything that's being put out there is
just like not doing it for me yeah i
know i feel that
um but here's the magic of the show and
it's what in my opinion has been the
greatest strength of the show always is
the writing like i
cackled like 15 times and i don't even
really even i chose that i love like i
never really like l-o-l
i
cackled like the writing is just so good
and so funny but it does feel like the
show is like
kind of morbid because we're watching
willie garson who's like the best and
he's being so funny and he's still
married to anthony and he's dead and
then big as dead on the show like it's
just kind of morbid but there is there
is magic there and for me what i'm
really struggling with is the miranda of
it all
because i have been like a miranda
spokesperson for for years i just really
believe that she was the best person on
the show and i just don't believe the
miranda that i know would turn into the
miranda that we're currently seeing
she's
like a karen and she's like a white
savior who's like racist like she's like
saying all this [ __ ] to her teacher
about her brains and like
it's just the miranda that i know i
don't think would have turned into this
person but it is like a like an
interesting
conversation on like people in our
culture like white saviors like who
think that they're like helping and
they're actually making things worse
um
but it's disappointing because like
miranda's my girl and she's insufferable
yeah
and i actually do think my call about
her exploring her sexuality is gonna
happen because
carrie's boss that she does a podcast
with is like this really cool young
lesbian and they like had this moment at
the funeral and then they teased coming
up like she's having marital problems
with steve so i think she might explore
her sexuality which would be very
interesting so does carrie host a
podcast or she just was like she's on
the podcast she's like she recently
started like taking pictures of people's
street style on instagram and like it
got really popular and now she's like an
instagram like digital person and she
started doing this podcast like it
already existed and she's like one of
the three like people who joined
panelists okay and um and she likes it
but she
like sucks at it
got it sounds like carrie yeah
so um and it was like annoying because
like right before big die they were like
gonna go to the hamptons and like i'm
like let me see the hamptons house like
i want to see carrie's life now like she
worked all these all this time like to
have the life that she has now i'm like
we can't even see it i barely got to see
the apartment before he dropped dead
yeah like the closet in the shower like
i got seen out of it damn yeah
sounds the reviews didn't look good you
know i've actually seen people really
enjoying it the thing is if you love the
show and you love the characters like
you will like it samantha so what they
say about samantha is you know the book
business isn't what it was and at one
point carrie just had to like fire
samantha as her publicist because she
couldn't pay her anymore which is like
[ __ ] because she's married to big
but whatever and apparently samantha
took it really hard dropped them all as
friends moved to london
and won't answer any of their calls or
texts so they did leave it kind of open
um but then at the funeral carrie was
like i didn't want any flowers and she
walks in and there's like this gorgeous
set of flowers on the coffin and the
women who run the funeral home are like
well we know you don't want any flowers
but these just arrived and they're
really gorgeous and here's the note and
it was from samantha so she texted
samantha thank you so it is like
open-ended like kim catrell could come
back um but it's just such a
mischaracterization of samantha like
samantha is the most ride-or-die [ __ ]
out there like who even knew carrie was
paying her all these years no i thought
she was doing a pro bono because carrie
had no [ __ ] money yeah so it was like
it had holes in it but it also was just
not who samantha was like samantha
didn't care about money samantha was so
successful on her own samantha was the
best friendship something so silly is
that she never would have let like a
30-year friendship end because of that
so i just feel like it was a
misrepresentation of who samantha was
yeah i totally agree i don't think
without samantha for me it's just not
it's not gonna work but if i like that
they left it open for her to come back
because that means they've left it open
for me to come back yeah and so the
fourth women who i think they're like
planning to make like another seat at
their lunch table is this woman who goes
to um the same school her kids go to
same school of charlotte and she's like
so cool and charlotte like wants to be a
friend on the pta and they're like
becoming friendly and i think that she's
gonna become like the fourth got it and
what's up with charlotte
um she i have a feeling we're gonna
explore one of her daughter's sexuality
because she didn't want to wear the
dress the dress the dress was like a
whole thing maybe she's non-binary i
think that's where they were going with
the whole dress thing um but her and
harry are just epic it's like lily
um who was the oldest daughter is very
much charlotte like concert pianist
loves this oscar de la renta dress that
she bought and the younger daughter is
like more of a tomboy um rose and her
and harry are really close so it's kind
of like perfect cute yeah it's cute and
harry's like still the best i think if
people came if they came between
charlotte and harry like people would
riot but you would think the same about
carrying big you would also think the
same it's like enough like we like steve
but you know steve has actually aged
extremely well it's interesting to see
like how who's aging they actually talk
about like she's go so miranda's going
back to school and cheryl's like well
are you gonna tie her hair like she's
fully gray she's like no
and charlotte like makes a face and so
they talk about like how old they're
getting actually like i would say they
spent a little too much time talking
about how old they're all getting it's
like we get it you're all talk about
something else yeah like we know steve
is going deaf like everyone's old it's
like a little annoying right but then
they also like disregard age when it
comes to you know her trying to
masturbate right but what about just
like sex at any age like why don't you
bring that to the podcast
100 percent
um
bloomer or planted carry bloom where
you're planted carrie um okay so that is
my sexist city recap and it's safe to
come back yep it was about 10 minutes
okay
we're going to put the description in
the podcast so podcasters you are now in
a safe space a spoiler-free zone yes you
are free you are good you are good you
are good come back come back come back
let's dive into the tv recap segment
okay which is brought to you by
manscaped santa baby it's holiday season
and you don't know what to get as a gift
or stocking stuffer well today's sponsor
manscaped has the tools to guarantee you
win this year's stock stocking stuffer
competition that's a mouthful manscaped
thank you for having an excuse to get
all the gifts he's been needing year
round they've changed more than four
million men worldwide for the better
so
if you have a man in your life who maybe
has some nose hairs that have been
bothering you some ear hairs some more
private genitalia hairs that have been
bothering you give the gift of subtlety
with manscaped their best-selling
product is the performance package 4.0
which is at the top of every man's wish
list this year you'll find the lawnmower
body trimmer which is the best trimmer
on the market for his balls back chest
the list goes on and the weed whacker
which is the ear hair ear and nose hair
trimmer
um let's not forget their famous liquid
formulation so they have ball deodorant
crop reviver ball toner they've got you
covered head to toe for the man in your
life great gift for your boyfriend for
your partner for your husband um
they also have
shampoo and conditioner that just
launched they have cologne infused body
wash
just like if your man's not taking care
of himself like here's a very subtle
gift like here i got you this whole
thing just use it all in the shower
goodbye
um whether it's for your partner dad
brother friend get them something they
will actually use and it's almost sure
to get a laugh get 20 off and free
shipping at manscaped.com with code
toast cheers to rocking the best gifts
of all the season a gift for him but
really a gift for you manscaped.com code
toast those are the best gifts yeah the
ones that are like self-serving yeah 100
that's a perfect gift for manning your
life i was actually thinking about
getting that um
he you sent me this heated blanket when
we were watching marco on qvc they kept
promoting this heated blanket that like
sometimes a heating pad is just not big
enough for the surface area of your body
or for me and brew together right so if
you get like a heated blanket it's like
a whole thing and it's been haunting me
ever since you sent me the like i almost
bought it on the tv
and now i'm thinking actually might get
it for ben for me
i
got it and i'm so excited for it to come
and that's bruno's christmas present
because he's gonna be so excited because
you know what this heating pad is not
big enough for the two of us it is so
[ __ ] small
and i just
really would have been enjoying watching
qvc like me too i feel like i am the
perfect audience member i spend so much
time at home i'm always shopping and i
love things like that make your life
easier you know and this is not an ad
for qvc we've just been watching a lot
because we haven't even spoken about how
margo recently got a gig on qvc and
she's been like killing it no and like
but even when her segment's over just i
keep watching they have so many like
great products they also have the best
prices unbeatable and it's just really
down to a science and i i've really been
enjoying like i find it to be very
soothing me too but you know i i'm gonna
wind up with a house full of crap if i
keep watching okay but like they were
having this thing did you see this like
big charging block no it's like okay
it's like a j it's it was 79
and you could plug in just like an
outlet to it you could charge your phone
obviously you could jump start a car it
had like insane voltage for like a
blackout actually was a really good
thing to have i saw something like that
on amazon recently and i thought it was
a really good thing to have you'll have
to send me the lamb i will it was on qvc
oh my gosh yeah jump start a car okay so
should we let's see ultimate girls trip
let's do ultimate girls trip which
wrapped up on peacock um i think
yesterday the final episode came out yes
what are your overall thoughts did you
like it i love for some reason maybe it
was just the headspace that i was in
when i watched the first five episodes i
couldn't get enough i'm like this is so
great so different so unique and then i
took a couple weeks off and yesterday i
watched the last three episodes six
seven five six and seven um
and i couldn't be bothered with the
stupidity like it was just infuriatingly
stupid okay so that's the opposite in
the beginning i was like this is a
little awkward like everyone in their
egos and i'm just like a little
uncomfortable and then by the rest of
the episodes i was like okay this is
moving like a well-oiled machine
and my issue with it only had to do with
like you know the drama the drama and
where everybody landed and i just i
found it to be like really sad
for ramona like beyond you know just
this she's not getting along with the
girls like there were so many instances
and i know she's like the
i hate in
being in a place where i have to defend
ramona because really she's quite
indefensible
but the way that the other women were
treating her and like the thing about
ramona is she says
untoward things to your face and it's
like what the [ __ ] why would you say
that why would you say luanne slept with
tom on the night yeah but what luanne
says in her confessionals and what
luanne says to other people about ramona
and behind her back is just as bad as
what ramona says to her face and like
they act like they're so like ramona's
not
savvy enough to navigate you know all of
her [ __ ] talking and she just kind of
like lays it bare and is really messy
but everybody else is doing the exact
same thing to her yes and then
also ramona like is the villain she is
in the wrong and so and everyone i mean
luanne playing like the victim of all
victims
it's so funny to watch how the people
from each other's
seasons uh city franchise yeah
like how they misrepresent each other so
and those are the people who are getting
along the least so it's ramona
it's cynthia and kenya and it's melissa
and teresa who
is
don't even know each other but the thing
about like in new york city yes
everybody kind of like rags on lou but
like lou did that [ __ ] like yeah and it
was time like embarrassing when lou was
[ __ ] insufferable it was the tom time
it was cabaret time it was she got
arrested like everything like right now
lou is in such a good place but like lou
is rewriting history yes and ramona is
there to say that's not how it happened
but the other girls are just like eating
it her truth like and
ramona did try to tell you about tom
like everybody tried to tell you about
tom and and even though it was a sad
situation like you can't say that ramona
wasn't trying to be a girlfriend no i
completely agree i think in a lot of
ways yes ramona was like being
insufferable but that's just like so
ramona but there was like a crazy amount
of hypocrisy
from the women um yes like especially
when
luanne and ramona were getting into it
on the boat and kenya somehow just like
inserted herself right in the center of
it and like did put hands on ramona and
like nobody said anything yeah even
though the kenya ramona drama starts on
the plane and as i was watching it they
do so many flashbacks in the show which
is annoying but so ramona's telling the
story of how she met someone yep
and and kenya is literally like pushing
the story being like you were cheating
on your husband like if i were telling
the story saying i was uh with my
husband we're going through a divorce i
met this guy we're flirting but you know
i'm married and she's like and then
someone's like you are still married
like you're not listening then and so
she calls her like offhand a [ __ ] which
is like since when is that the biggest
defense of all time no you know what i
thought kenya was like really pushing
ramona in that scenario and like
misrepresenting what a nice story that
ramona was trying to tell everybody on
the
especially kenya and luanne like are
really pushing ramona's buttons
unfortunately ramona is not savvy enough
to like just put it out of her head and
be like i know they're trying to get at
me and she gives them the reaction that
they want and every morning she says
she's not she's looking at herself in
the mirror and she's like i'm gonna keep
my mouth shut and she becomes the
villain and she's making it so easy for
them but like then not only did really
do they push her buttons and also like
you can't talk about the tom situation
and lie like that you know ramona's
gonna come and correct you and she's
gonna look like an [ __ ] yeah fell
into your trap but then now she's on the
outs with everyone she's on this island
of her own and she brings them all to
john's house and she's like clearly like
feeling herself having a moment she's
already confided in the women like i
have nothing to go home to everybody
knows she's like this like kind of sad
older lady
and the way that kenya and luanne evil
were at that dinner just made me so sad
for ramona it was so sad no it was it
was so evil like the not only it was
kenya's idea and luanne's execution and
just together it was so mean-spirited
and you know ramona had to pretend like
she didn't care yeah obviously she did
she did that at least and didn't just
give them more reactions they would
laugh at her more like yeah it was so
mean girl and it's like kenya is the
most popular girl in the house and
everybody loves her and everybody's like
following her and so and ramona is the
biggest loser i'm so cindy is giving her
a run for her money no i'm sorry
cynthia is the biggest loser we're gonna
get into that the biggest loser but
ramona is the most on the outs the most
disliked and when the most popular
person is constantly like
uh you know messing with
the the loser it's it doesn't feel right
no i'm sorry ramona did say one thing
extremely factual the entire time when
like cynthia it's just like getting on
this weird hill uh you didn't let me do
my glam 25 minutes earlier like so
stupid at teresa's dinner like the most
cynthia was like needing some argument
because she was like becoming so
irrelevant and she likes oh everyone's
hating ramona let me talk some [ __ ] on
ramona too and the remote's like you
guys are so bored all you do is talk
about me and that's like what really set
kenya off and you know ramona was
speaking 100 facts this entire weekend
would have been so lame without ramona
like everyone's just getting along
pretending to be someone they're not
theresa everyone was pretending to be
someone they're not fraudulent vibes
thank god for ramona 100 and i think
this example i'm about to share really
sums up like what is so wrong they all
were taking pictures with michael doing
a photo shoot yes
yes
yes doing a photo shoot on the beach
like feeling cringy themselves like
cringy you know but like modeling as
much as they can for you know they're
they are who they are and
ramona is doing the same thing as
everyone else just the editing just like
trying to like you know be cute for the
pictures and they're all like laughing
at her in their confessionals in front
of her and the editing was like
like and in that situation she's done
nothing wrong like or even when they're
doing the twerk off
and ramon like none of them can twerk no
and not even cynthia and ramona's
they're like
uh trying her best and and kenya who
they're not even on speaking terms it's
like pulling up your dress and like
watching her button it's like and ramona
just she doesn't even react to it
everybody's constantly poking fun at her
and at her age like it just feels really
mean no and yes i agree and i know that
this is like hella
unpopular but it's just so easy to go
along with like ramona sex trade it's
harder it's honestly more creative for
looking at it with a more nuanced eye
and i just
i don't know like i think the whole
thing started off on a bedford because
they all like hated ramona with the room
thing but i didn't really feel like
ramona did anything that bad with the
room thing and it was just after that it
was just like down the hill she went
yeah and she didn't help herself at all
but i thought like when she had the
conversation she was wasted for that
whole day i know and that's the other
like i just wish she didn't drink so
much because then she just like digs
herself in deeper and she never does
that in new york and lou said that too
she doesn't drink on new york that's a
big she always has a drink but she's
never drunk she's never drunk and she
knows exactly how to act but the second
she has a drink she becomes like old
ramona and that's why she doesn't drink
anymore yeah and that was really
frustrating because it's like there's no
getting through to her we're just gonna
have to wait till tomorrow and that's
just like frustrating about alcohol in
general yeah just really like you're
never gonna you're never gonna win the
argument yeah but when she was having
like that post bailey bowl
conversation with
kyle and teresa yes and they really were
taking the time to understand her
nobody had done that yet nobody had done
that i felt like i understood her even
more i almost wish that she didn't
practice what she was gonna say to kenda
because she used the good surprise on
them yeah and then when she went to
kenya she was acting because she was
trying to remember what she said but
what she was saying at the table did
seem extremely genuine you know i just
feel so torn about kenya because
i on her on her show i think she's just
like evil like what i'll never forget
kenya more hair care like just i think
she's done so many evil things and she's
like really mean to a lot of people who
are nice to her
but she was really confusing me because
like when she gave that trip to teresa
that was so nice
it was just seemed so out of character
for her and then also giving um
no no that was cynthia sorry no she was
just doing a lot of things and everyone
was so drawn to her energy like i must
be wrong about her because everyone in
the house i couldn't get enough of her i
don't know the if if i'm going based on
the other women it's like who you were
in turks and caicos was like your
absolute best figure and very very
phony but
i think the person who was most
themselves was kyle
yes
but kyle like
is shrewd enough that even if she like
you know wanted to have an issue with
someone or something like rubbed her the
wrong way aside from like the bailey cue
thing
she really like is not she i think she
just made the decision like i'm here to
have fun i'm coming off good i don't
want to be confrontational yeah well
let's talk about cynthia i would say who
took the biggest l the entire trip yeah
and yeah i was like oh she's going to
turn around now oh she's going to turn
it around now and then it's like the
last dinner i'm like i don't think she's
turning it around no and like the first
few times i was like you know what i i
just know that feeling of like you're
just upset and like feeling off and you
don't know how to get out of it and
everyone's making progress because
you're in your own head you're falling
even further behind yes and like okay
it's a new day i'm going to start a new
i'm gonna try again and i get that but
she could never like get out of it and
also she continued to be so sensitive
about really small stuff and it was just
not the right environment for her no not
at all and you know what it's like sad
because now she's not on atlanta anymore
that was like her last
moment and she just looked like an
enormous loser yeah
like really big yeah no it was it was
quite sad and then theresa was just out
here like putting on a full-blown act
i'm sure for melissa it was like very
jarring like i know that and everyone's
like oh twist i'm surprised how sweet
you are yeah because she's literally
being fake like no and here's like it's
this is why it's like so annoying that
you can't cross-reference but like when
um
when ramona said on the boat that luanne
slept with tom the first on the first
date which is a is a bad thing to say
like it's very uncalled for its private
information whatever but that's the kind
of conversation that flies in real
houses in new york city yes just want to
say that and then teresa got so upset
that ramona said that and it's like wait
where are you out here last year
accusing evan of cheating like and
talking about that's so true and it's
just like
hypocrisy it's hypocrisy and it's like
unless theresa were to say that now on
this boat it's like irrelevant to the
situation but like you say and have done
crazier things can i tell you though the
best part of like everyone like coming
to lose defense lou rewriting history is
when teresa like went around the table
at her dinner and said really nice
things about all the women she's just
recently met and she was like luanne
like i will protect you like we're gonna
give you a backbone and the way i'm like
[ __ ] like you know i can go back to
the backbone thing like you said i have
no background you said i'm a pushover
even though she never said that that was
just like so great like luanne you your
storyline is so fraudulent you've made
it seem to everyone like you don't have
a backbone so now they're all saying
getting knocked down by a girl that's
what you painted the picture so now
they're all just reciting what you have
told them and now you're suddenly
offended like they painted you as this
victim because you because you've been
victim mentality the whole time like lou
is not the victim on real housewives of
new york ever like the thing she's the
oppressor okay here's another great
example so ramona said you know you
slept with tom on the first night
slut-shaming not cool
what remember what luanne said to sonia
in the van in the hamptons about
sleeping with
trash and sleeping with guys on the
first date 15 guys yeah and that like he
married me like literally it's worse
than what ramon is
so true they were all just like on a
delusional island where like they've
never done anything like that in the
past and everything ramon is doing is
like so taboo and they've literally done
30 times like very recently here's the
thing ramona didn't get the memo that we
were all faking we're all faking it
we're all on our best behavior what we
do on our shows we're not gonna do here
because this is the all-stars and you're
not gonna get caught like that can i
tell you i know everyone's like so
anti-ramona i just feel like we're
making a lot of good points like i think
we actually might turn some people i
just want to say that no and i agree
it's just like if you hate romano you
hate ramona but here's the other thing i
saw everyone want to do some things just
like in the off like you know when she's
waking up for breakfast and like being
[ __ ] annoying and stuff that would
make me if i were there like i don't
want to be around of course but as a
viewer and like watching these dynamics
at play it is extremely hard to be the
person in the house that like
everybody's laughing at talking [ __ ]
about and like
at least she does try and like i thought
when she had that conversation with
luanne um
in the beach in the beach hut i thought
she was extremely genuine she wasn't up
to her old apologies like season one
ramona like it was she does do that a
lot so it must just get like monotonous
like she is really genuine when she
apologizes and then she'll literally do
the same thing she just forgets but then
when she was also describing how when
growing up she would just zone out i do
feel like
she's awesome i thought that was
extremely a great explanation for like
some of her bizarre quirks yeah yeah
where she's literally not listening to
and she's still spoken about her
childhood like a lot on housewives
almost to the point where she brings up
her childhood and people are like stop
and i guess i never really understood
why she was bringing it up but i felt
like i really got to know ramona at a
glance at that beach conversation with
melissa and kyle she brings it up i
think when she really is in a bad place
and she needs to like explain to these
women why she is the way that she is but
i still don't feel like we even know a
fraction of what she experienced you
know so it's actually she doesn't um
like wield it as an excuse for
everything yeah i think sometimes it's
like okay i gotta let these women know
who like why me otherwise i'm never
gonna make
any headway so all in all i thought it
was like a pretty good show i know that
there's other versions of it coming out
like a couple like b listers and the
berkshires i think that's what the show
is called the b let's go listen to the
berkshires and i don't think it'll
translate i think this was like a once
in a lifetime thing because it was like
the best of the best
cast great house
and i just don't know if it'll translate
to the other spin-offs they're planning
on doing
yeah i agree and just to go back to
luanne one more time um
like what ramona said about lou not cool
yeah
but then all the women watch how lou
like took a shot out of the mouth and
kissed a married man yeah right and said
that he's dming her right and that's
just okay behavior the hypocrisy was
blinding it was blinding so anyways i
just it made me
it was just frustrating to know like no
one agrees yeah i know like we're so in
the minority here yeah but um
it was good i be listening to the
berkshires looks really quite atrocious
an atrocity i will watch it just because
it's like actually seems like crazy it
actually might be so bad that it's even
better than this yeah and like these are
all women who are off the show nothing
to lose i think we're going to get a a
whole array of ramonas yeah i agree you
know everyone else they have like too
much to lose to be crazy yeah but like
maybe if you're just crazy enough you'll
get back on i agree it's gonna be
batshit bat [ __ ] b-list in the
berkshires now i'm actually looking
forward to it
we talked ourselves into it yeah no the
cast is like
crazy like brandy lanville tamara
vicki that's like
taylor armstrong oh wow it's really like
crazy okay maybe it will be good phaedra
um you know what i also spent all day
watching yesterday was the sex lives of
college girls i do know and i know that
you didn't watch it i'm here to tell you
like you will absolutely love it it's an
amazing show no you said it made you
feel old you know what i got over that
extremely quickly because the show was
very good hilarious writing like i
cackled okay so many moments and also i
just need you to watch it because there
is a character her name is kimberly who
i just found out is timothy chalamet's
sister her name is pauline chalamet she
plays kimberly like this
freak
she is
not visually just personality wise
reminds me so much of dana from the
redheads and it's and i think i figured
out why it's because this girl is like
she actually has this admirable
confidence like she's so sure of who she
is and going to college and meeting all
these new people like it's not going to
change that she is who she is even if
that is like a little quirky and she
says these like quirky bizarre things
with so much confidence that like no one
questions her she reminds me so much of
dana i cannot go over it so i just need
you to watch it to like tell me if you
see it i will and you know what the show
like the premise looks good and even i
don't mind if you say it's good i i will
actually that is something that i would
watch so i'm going to watch it so we can
spoil it it's for college roommates and
just they all have their own story lines
it's by mindy caleb the premise is so
good i don't know why that doesn't
happen more often yeah and it's by mindy
kaling so it's actually like they refer
to social media and stuff like actually
well because this girl like likes this
guy and she one of her friends is like
put up a story and like see if he sees
it and then like it's just a good
accurate representation of like how
social media plays out in college where
i feel like sometimes 90 year olds are
talking about instagram i just feel like
the
the culture is there like mindy kaling
has a really good pulse on the
generation and because it's mainly
killing like it's super diverse and not
in like the corny way it's like just
really good and the writing is great the
only thing i feel weird about
is i know that
the actors are like in their 20s but
we're supposed to be watching 18 year
olds they just got to college and it was
like really kind of um
wow i'm having a speechless but like
inappropriate nothing appropriate but
what i'm looking for like
sexual food no no it's just like sex
scenes but it's like
not vulgar but like
it's like i don't know what you're
trying to me neither no so what is it
very like explicit like explicit that's
a great word yeah well because we're
seeing stuff yeah we're seeing like
major sex scenes and which just feels
weird because the characters are
supposed to be 18. we're watching 18
year olds having sex even though they
are not
they're supposed to be that's something
like we felt weird about it like the
that's interesting that was the only
thing okay i'll let you i'm gonna watch
it so i'll let you know if that sticks
out it's just great and like i honestly
can't decide which girl i like best
because the day they show parts and
stuff no not part of boobs yeah oh yeah
boobs are always
tushy
okay and then like sex positions no p no
v no p no v not that i can remember i
mean it's hbo you never know oh you know
what there was a little pig there was a
little baby they go to like a naked
party hbo loves to throw in one p to get
the people talking i actually think you
would like it because the sh i mean
maybe it's because i've literally never
been to a real college except yours it
reminded me of colgate like just like
the vibe it's in vermont so it's like
fall it's just like a small school yeah
it's essex it's not like a huge college
oh my god that sounds really great i'm
gonna watch it yeah it's really good i
really liked it and i just love the
characters like at first i'm like who do
i like best i liked like leighton the
best because she was just like this rich
girl from the upper east side but then
they're all just so nuanced i think i
ended up like liking bella the best or
that girl kimberly who was such a weirdo
the dana girl um
she really grows on you i'm sure that
she will it's really good
okay oh great and one of the girls her
mom is like a really famous senator
played by sherry shepard who's just
hilarious the show was just perfect like
i have i wish there were i wish there
was like 10 seasons out so i could just
like binge because now i'm like such a
trendsetter i'll be waiting a while damn
yeah so good i give it 10 out of 10.
great
that's our show okay now i feel fully
recapped i feel unburdened yeah me as
well i can go into this weekend alarm
free living all of the tings it's a long
episode and enjoy living life so thank
you guys for being toasters next week is
our final week of tmt for 2021 yes
reminder the 17th of december is our
final episode and
that's really exciting
2022 is almost here
you got to start thinking about
resolutions and [ __ ] no [ __ ] that i just
feel like when you're having resolutions
are for broken people i i'm fully whole
like as a pregnant person like there's a
lot of change coming like i don't feel
the need to like you're exempt no it's
like i'm gonna go through so much and i
also need to make sure to get my steps
no you're [ __ ] exempt from that
[ __ ] okay i do think that is when
you graduate from resolution making i
agree it's too late for you when you're
making a child thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning test the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitch or public radio i have
ready to catch box all the places
wherever you listen to the podcast five
nights a month just leave a five-star
review about a beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing day and if you made it to the
end of this episode wanna go drop an
emoji on our most recent instagram
of the letter b for the b list in the
berkshires love that have a great
weekend we love you and we'll see you
back in studio on monday bye